[Music]
that's suny lee
celebrating her big win on thursday the
u.s gymnast won a gold medal for the
women's individual
all around gymnastics at the tokyo
olympics
[Music]
the 18 year old olympian crushed her an
even bar set
making her the fifth consecutive
american to claim the major victory
with a total of 57.433 points
suny landed on top beating rebecca
andrade of brazil who won
silver and angelina malnikova of russia
who took home the bronze
suny's family and friends in minnesota
went wild as they watched her soar to
victory
who else was in suny's corner her
teammate simone biles who cheered from
the sidelines
after simone withdrew from the team
competition on tuesday
citing a medical issue it was announced
on wednesday that she was also pulling
out from the individual competition
i do feel any pressure now that sort of
all eyes are on you sort of following on
social media
um yeah i think that
competing was the most precious a
statement on behalf of usa gymnastics
read quote
after further medical evaluation to
focus on her mental health
it has been announced that simone biles
is out of the all-around
i feel like people think i'm like an
alien or i'm inhuman
at times i'm normal i have emotions i
have feelings
the organization also praised simone's
decision and applauded her bravery
in prioritizing her well-being
physically i feel
good i'm in shape emotionally that kind
of varies on the time in the moment
on tuesday the gymnast joined her fellow
teammates for an interview with the
today show
where she opened up about the pressure
and stress that comes with competing at
the highest level
coming here to the olympics and being
the head
star of the olympics is not an easy feat
so we're just trying to take it one day
at a time and we'll see
biles has since received a slew of
support from athletes and celebrities
praising her for putting her mental
health first justin bieber michelle
obama
rhys witherspoon and fellow olympian
adam rippon
all took to social media to share how
proud they are of simone in her decision
and eti spoke with her former dancing
with the stars pro sasha farber
who didn't hold back his admiration for
simone's unrivaled work ethic
i feel so much love for her she
is such a hard worker and i remember you
know being in the gym with her
we had so much fun but there is just you
know this proves that she's human and
it's so nice to for america to be behind
her and have
she's having all the support because it
is
it must be so much pressure and she's
the star of the team
and simone is clearly feeling the love
the 24 year old gymnast
took to twitter on wednesday to thank
everyone writing
the outpouring love and support i've
received has made me realize
i'm more than my accomplishments and
gymnastics which i never truly believed
[Music]
before